ever said yes and immediately regretted
it you're not alone in this video we
dive into the art of saying no without
the guilt here's the truth your problem
isn't how to say no it's feeling like
you're not allowed to every reluctant
yes costs you more than just time it
drains your emotional bandwidth leading
to burnout and resentment but here's the
GameChanger the most successful people
don't say yes to everything they say no
to focus on what truly matters you'll
learn the bridge method a simple
three-step technique to say no while
strengthening relationships first
acknowledge the request second state
your reality and third offer a smaller
alternative and here's the kicker every
no you say is a yes to your priorities
energy and
growth ready to transform your life
watch the full video to master the art
of saying no and unlock your best self
don't forget to share your boundary wins
in the comments you might just just
Inspire someone else to take control of
their life too let's do this together
see you in the full video